in this video i'm going to be talking
about three things you
should not do if you want to get views
and subscribers on youtube this year
the two most important youtube metrics
for growing your channel in 2021
and some breaking news when it comes to
youtube social media
and e-commerce that you need to know so
let's get straight
into it um if you haven't seen there's
some new articles from business insider
as well as forbes
and e-marketer and what those revealed
was that the onset of the coronavirus
pandemic has ramped up social media
usage across all platforms and there's
no
sign of decline anytime soon so if
you've been asking yourself
man is it too late to get into this
youtube thing is it too late to get on
social media the answer is no
you know the world has shifted and
there's been a massive surge of growth
on these platforms which is a huge
opportunity for you to grow this year
now listen to this over 3 billion people
use social media
but nearly 150 more
have joined compared to pre-pandemic
estimates
so there's been this mass 150 people
because again you're like
who's my viewer who's gonna watch my
content who's gonna be paying attention
to my channel
like 150 new people plus the other three
billion people that are online right so
that begins to like widen the amount of
people there is to reach
you might be like man competition is
rising yes but opportunity is rising as
well
but then of course the second question
is always like man how do i turn this
into a business and maybe
you want to work from home be your own
boss write your own checks
when it comes to you know building your
influence on youtube
this article revealed um on
e-marketer that the most consequential
digital story of 2020 was the widespread
embrace of e-commerce during the
pandemic
unexpectedly accelerating the channel's
progress by almost two years
and when it says the channel it means
e-commerce progress
was accelerated by two years
what does that mean it means that the
adoption of people shopping online
clicking amazon links clicking affiliate
links
purchasing things online has been
accelerated
by listen they estimated that e-commerce
was going to be a nearly 700 billion
dollar industry
it is now over 100 billion
higher because of the pandemic
so if you're saying man how do i build a
high influence reaching people
and high profit youtube channel this is
the time to be doing it
and i get it like it might be
frustrating like how do i beat the
algorithm how do i get the confidence to
be on camera
you know how do i overcome a lot of
those things but my friends
this is the data and it just shows us
that there's massive opportunity
to be growing your influence with
youtube and
monetizing in multiple different
strategic ways but how do you do that in
this video i'm going to share
three tips and specifically some things
you don't want
to do but hit like if you're pumped
about the future of youtube and building
your influence
and these are three things you should
not do if you want to get views this
year on youtube the first mistake
is you want to avoid long form content
if you want to reach new people
okay you want to avoid long-form content
now
i take this with like a grain of salt
i'm not
saying don't misquote me that you should
never do long-form content i'm saying
if you want to reach new people and if
you want to grow
this year and trigger growth you should
avoid
long-form content so i did a quick
search and i typed in
how to get motivated on youtube and the
top
four results are five minutes long eight
minutes long
12 minutes long and 16 minutes long okay
just
one little test but here's my thing you
should be doing
shorter content especially when you're
just
starting if we look at the top videos on
think media
of history 3.4 million views 3 million
views 2.8 million
2.4 million 2 million 2 million views
these are all like basically
2 million plus viewed videos the longest
one
is 19 minutes there's 14 there's 15
there's 11 they're seven and they're
seven
so i just want to challenge you shorter
is better for some of you vloggers i
don't know if you've noticed but like
casey neistat's vlogs lately seven
minutes five minutes six minutes five
minutes
you know you know nine minutes four
minutes
uh six minutes and so you gotta be i
think
if you're starting out and why is this
because like nobody knows you yet
nobody trusts you yet and i believe this
is a huge trend going into 2021
that that people have shorter attention
spans and they'll
maybe invest longer amounts of time
later
but it's gonna start shorter like you do
a search you see
three top options if if all look decent
and one is like eight minutes one is 18
and one is 45 i'm clicking on eight
first like if i you know all things
created equal
like it's too busy i got too much to do
i got too many other youtube videos
to watch i want to challenge you avoid
long-form content when you're starting
out
and it kind of makes me think about like
dating you know what i mean like i don't
have you ever
have done speed dating before tell me in
the comments have you ever been on a bad
date
a weird date have you ever been you know
you sat across and you're like what the
heck how did i get into this that's why
people do speed dating because they're
like okay
like quickly i can make my decision
whether or not
people are speed dating you on youtube
do you realize that that's like it's
what we're doing we're like
okay if the hook didn't get me if like
they said something i was like that was
sort of sketchy like whatever
we speed date we want the short amount
we speed date the person then we go oh
this is interesting oh wow the unfolding
of this video was keeping my attention
hmm but when i think about that when
you're
starting to date somebody you're not
trying to go on vacation
for two weeks with that person right
like when you first start dating someone
you're like listen
can we just like let's get coffee that's
like day one
second date hey how about dinner and a
movie if you're like hey
could we do like a whole day together
dude i haven't met you yet we could walk
the dog we could work out together work
out together am i gonna sweat around you
like oh we just met let's work out walk
the dog
let's watch a movie do a puzzle then we
could cuddle
you're like dude i freaking just okay so
shorter dates on youtube when you're
starting out
because you may have been in this
situation before ladies you're sitting
across from a dude
and he's just going on and on and on and
on and on about his career asking you no
questions he's like as an accountant
i really enjoy because you know you're
wasting the person's time or like how
did i get into this and they're gonna
bail
so don't try to start with four hour
youtube videos or even necessarily live
streams or longer form content
by the way even if you go live be short
be brief be bright be fun and be done
when you're starting out so we have a
upcoming youtube strategy workshop and
this is one of the first strategies
i'm gonna be going through 10 on the
workshop but shorter videos
are better than longer videos especially
when you're starting out and
in 2021 basically on this youtube
strategy workshop i'm gonna be revealing
our think media
playbook for 2021 and this is one of our
pillars
we're gonna be pushing for shorter
videos you'll be like well i see long
videos from you all the time
fair it's not either or but i'm saying
if you really want to get reach you're
going to want to go shorter so how do
you do that couple tips trim the fluff
get to the point half short and twice
strong i want to challenge you
if you have a video in your timeline and
you're editing it and it's 13 minutes
try to make it seven
like try to really cut it in half and
and watch how results
can change and then i think a goal is
three to 15 minutes especially if you're
starting out
shorter definitely is more powerful than
longer
especially when somebody doesn't know
you yet because they they're going to
want to speed date you
so let me ask you what do you think is
the ideal video length like let me know
type that in the comments and how long
are your videos
do you think they're too long could they
be shorter
could you experiment i i see some
vloggers that we coach
uh and there sometimes they got 18 19 24
26 minute videos i'm like man experiment
with five minute videos
and it might be like that kind of cooks
my noodle i don't know if i can get it
down to five that's the challenge
try to make it half short and twice
strong and let me know in the comments
your answer to that question but hey
you are watching the coffee with cannell
show and these are three things you
should not do
if you want to get views this year smash
like
if you're getting value and if we're
just meeting my name is sean cannell and
my passion is
helping people grow their influence with
youtube grown a couple different youtube
channels to a million subscribers a
couple to a hundred thousand and
my biggest passion and what i'm most
proud of is our students we've helped a
lot of people grow from zero
to that silver play button or from zero
to full-time income and full-time
freedom online
so if you want more content like that
make sure you click subscribe
on this video but let's get into the
second mistake and that is
lazy titles and thumbnails
man lazy titles and thumbnails you
should not
cut corners when it comes to titling
your videos
or creating your thumbnails and you
might be like this isn't new information
but let's dive a little bit deeper okay
now the two most important metrics on
youtube in 2021 and this is worth like
writing down like screen shotting like
really paying attention here right
our number one click-through rate these
are the two most
this is it this is it it's click-through
rate
are people clicking through your videos
when your video is shown to somebody and
recommended
or even if they type in a search and you
get to rank for a while because by the
way when you put out new content
youtube tests it it puts it places so if
people
see it but they don't click on it
you lose and that affects your
click-through rate so
the higher the click-through rate the
better on the workshop we'll go deeper
into
like all kinds what's the best
click-through rate i mean it depends on
the niche it depends on all kinds of
things
but you just need to know number one
click-through rate super
the most important metric how's that
going to be influenced we'll talk about
it in a second
and the second one is avd average view
duration
okay average view duration this video
recently crushed
a little christmas special that omar and
heather put out and the average
iteration you see the green
arrow there green arrow is up our
typical average view duration
is three to four minutes a little over
four minutes this one was
seven minutes and 13 seconds thus it
says views are up as more people are
watching longer than usual
more watch time more average view
duration so your question is how do i
increase my click-through rate and how
do i increase
my average view duration how do i know
these are the most important metrics
because this is what youtube's telling
us when you look at your top videos in
this period
this is actually looking at our top
videos over the last year
on our channel think media it says
here's the amount of views and here's
the average view duration
so what are we trying to increase we're
trying to say how can we increase
the average view duration on our videos
so the strategy number two
is increase click-through rate and ctr
means click-through rate
how do you do that three ways title
topic and thumbnail
so title like and we're gonna actually
be going deeper some of you jumped into
the starter kit and there's details in
the description that sales going on a
little bit a while longer
uh we have our title guide you gotta get
really good really not just writing
titles but
understanding here's the thing to
research headlines
it's almost like uh blog headlines
newspaper headlines
like as a youtube strategist and as
somebody that wants to start
uh really dominating on youtube and stop
dabbling
in 2021 if you walk to the grocery store
sean i never go to the grocery store
it's a lockdown i haven't been there
okay
but if you do you know how there's all
these magazines there
like cosmopolitan you know like like i
can't believe
prince henry and like are they gonna get
a divorce like you know like there's all
these
like look at headlines that the magazine
uh headlines the magazine in in four
words uh they'll say 36 ways to get him
to notice you like pretty powerful if
you want him to notice you you know
like you start looking those type of
thinking is what you want to master
it's not just like how to write a good
title but really how to grab attention
with
words is something to really think about
title
thumbnail uh thinking about your
thumbnail design and then the biggest
one though that gets not
nobody ever talks about it they just
like it's titled thumbnail no it's topic
as well the question is what video
topics would your target audience be
most likely to click on that's a
powerful question
what video topics would your target
audience be most likely to click on
because here if it's the right topic and
the right information is on the other
side
of that title and thumbnail people can
forgive like
i don't care if like it's not my
favorite thumbnail but i really want to
see that information
i really want to see the promise to that
entertaining headline that curiosity
creating
title i really want to see what's on the
other side so you got to know that and
we're going to be going
deep on that on the youtube strategy
workshop as far as coming up with
the right video topics for your niche
your category
your topic mistake number three hit like
if you're getting video
ignoring video editing ignoring
video editing remember these videos the
top videos on think media
between 3.4 million views and 2 mil 1.9
on all of these guys these are all big
hitters these are some
heavy hitters all of these videos have
been edited
you know right now i'm doing this
training in a live stream setting
this video might do all right but this
isn't going to get a million views
it's knowing different content formats
i'm talking about if you want to get
views in 2021 you want to blow up you
want to get noticed you want to grow
your channel
you want to get the awareness listen you
can do this show
this called coffee with kennel you can
do this at other times it's another
content format so i can connect with you
at a deeper level
but if you want to blow up you got to
focus on video editing and all these
videos
have been edited so that they're they're
sharp their attention they get to the
point
trim the fluff so strategy number three
is you gotta increase average view
duration
avd you got to increase average view
duration okay
so one way to do that is to improve your
video hooks to really master and study
at the beginning of a video how are you
gonna open
and how are you gonna change the way you
open videos uh what are you gonna say
what are you gonna show
uh how how are you going to in a way
quote unquote
sell the viewer on watching the rest of
the video because if you can't
keep their attention for the beginning i
do this all the time i
i click on people's videos and
i'm stunned by how many people don't
know this the majority don't
like great people and this is why we've
got our video ranking academy program
and different things because we just
help people like kind of
see this but like my friend i was
watching this content and i wanted to
learn about
tax strategies but i wanted him to like
give me an idea of what was coming up
like at least somewhere in the first
hopefully 50 seconds of the videos
if not the first five minutes and he was
saying about everything other than like
actually selling me on do i actually
already know this are you going to share
some new stuff
you got to open up your video powerfully
so think about how you can improve your
video hooks
trim the fluff with video editing take
time to trim the fluff if you shoot for
an hour this is why when you shoot for
an hour you edit it down to seven
minutes
you trim the fluff for video editing and
that's why that's the power of youtube
and video because you are serving the
viewer
by putting that time into video editing
getting to the point fast and then use
b-roll and b-roll could be
images you know in a way i'm using
b-roll you know i'm actually using
slides and this is a powerpoint and this
software is called stream yard
think media tools if you're ever
curious.com if you're ever curious about
the tools we use that's
think mediatools.com so we use things
like this
hopefully like things are flying around
big
small seance like you know try to think
about how to make things more visually
stim
stimulating and more interesting and
b-roll of course
would be uh those clips what does b-roll
mean
a-roll when you film is like if you were
doing talking head
and there you are hey sean here welcome
to my video powerful hook
to keep you watching hi and while you
talk in
in the a role b-roll is what you would
lay on top of that that's the
a-roll the b-roll the clips above that
on your video editor timeline
and when you talk about wow social media
is blowing up you know you see like a
little graphic of like an arrow going up
and of course
you've seen this in videos you're
watching but there's certain things when
you really understand
man how do i keep viewer attention that
is definitely one way
to power up your videos so if you found
these three strategies valuable hit like
i'm going to be sharing uh 10 of them so
it's the think media youtube playbook
10 strategies for rapidly growing your
youtube channel and getting more views
on our upcoming youtube strategy
workshop which is all about the new
rules of youtube success
and and creating your stress-free
youtube growth plan for winning on
youtube in 2021
and so this is coming up january 2nd
um there will be a replay available for
a while and
i'm excited it's a four hour training
heather taurus is going to be
doing a session omar alta corey tony
ariola
and myself doing a couple sessions um
really if you wanted to look inside
of think media's playbook we i think we
got about four million views
uh in 2020
and we also of course learned a lot you
know we
don't think we know everything like we
test a lot of strategies we're like
youtube scientists
we have a lot of wins a lot of results
we also
make mistakes and you get to go further
faster
by learning from our different team and
our content creators and everything
we're going to do
and the changes that we're going to make
in light of how the algorithm
is acting and all those types of things
if that's of interest to you
there's a link in the description down
below the best way to get a ticket
is to actually it's part of the starter
kit like so our youtube starter kit
there's a sale that we've been doing for
the holidays that's ending very soon
and so if you're interested and you
found these tips valuable
then um just grab the you can grab the
starter kit at tubestarterkit.com i'll
put a link to the ticket as well
but it costs like three times as much
just to buy a ticket to the strategy
workshop
so if you want like our title guide our
thumbnail uh trainings our video ideas
our 51 money money-making ideas
some tips on gear and a ticket to our
new year's strategy workshop that's all
included
uh with the youtube starter kit
tubestarterkit.com
if you are interested in that and
you could see all the links in the
description down below
and i cannot wait to help you go further
faster growing your youtube channel in
2021
if you're ready to shift from dabbling
and you really want to start dominating
investing in yourself investing in your
strategy
iron sharpens iron getting around others
that are crushing it
getting around other people and learning
from not just myself but even video
ranking academy students like we have so
many students in different
niches doing so many cool things getting
incredible results
so it's going to be an awesome event
can't be there live you can uh watch the
replay
and really get your game on your hustle
right your grind on your focus fixed
your your napkin strategy for winning on
youtube in 2021
written out we're also going to help you
plan an entire year
of content in one hour so
think about the leverage of that and not
just like random content but strategic
video topics so you can boost that avd
and that ctr so anyways uh check out all
the details in the description down
below
this is the coffee with kennel show
where i bring you on to talk about
uh your questions regarding
youtube um but i hope you're doing well
and i just got back from
the seattle area christmas with family
and uh my son is a little over three
months old now and uh
life is crazy new parent
kind of sleep my wife's amazing she's
very gracious he's a pretty chill baby
we're pretty grateful for him if you
haven't met him yet here he is there he
is sean bradley kennel
there's my wife sonia and uh homie's
actually about
like a week over three months now and uh
we are
with hearts full and sleep low
we are pressing on to the future but hey
coffee with kennel let's uh
get it rockin we got gary smith on today
uh gary who are you uh what's your
channel about and how can i help
oh wait what's going on sean um well i
started off doing um
i started out doing sneakers i'm really
into sneakers but
kind of on my behalf a little bit lazy
with it um honestly
um but you know a lot of times when i'm
into like camera gear
or trying to see what lens does what
like the m50 i reached recently
purchased
but my question was for you was um what
do you think
i know you have the starter kit but what
about the academy which one
would you think would be ideal for right
now
yeah that's a that's a great question i
mean i think that uh
anyone who's super serious about youtube
uh video ranking academy
is gonna help you grow um it's just i
think different opportunities
of of an investment you know the starter
kit
is on sale it's 37 in about a week it
goes up to
97 so now is the definitely time to get
it
okay um and it's that jump start because
of course
one way or another our destination for
you and our entire community is the same
we want to help
10 000 purpose-driven people create a
full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with youtube
and so the starter kit is to get started
to get going and a ton of valuable
resources
even actually if you're established
video ranking academy
our current special on it is 997
on our website it's a 3 000 program so
a definitely different level of a price
investment
but when it comes to video ranking
academy it's not you know just a bundle
of resources
it is a ton of video trainings that you
can take at your own pace
it is like an 80-page workbook pdf that
you can print out
walks you through everything um it is
the private facebook group
that is highly engaged and highly active
a lot of people have been
a part of facebook groups and they might
notice like okay there's no one here
and one of the ways we're able to make
video reagan academy so dynamic
is because think media is 13 people full
time
and so we do welcome parties on zoom and
chris and alina host those and people
get to know each other inside of vra
tony does weekly tips of the week
we do um monthly the vra show with other
members in there
uh every month we do q a with myself or
another one of our certified youtube
coaches
so the level of training there
that you get is is really just out of
this world and i kind of think about it
you know a thousand dollars is a big
investment that's the current price and
the price always is has been going up
over the years because we keep adding to
it and keep
keeping it current but at the same time
if i was to go over to my community
college here or my college unlv in vegas
that is the if i audited one marketing
class that's how much it would cost
and now one marketing class wouldn't
even be close
like what video racket academy is i mean
you know what i mean like
you'd get like the professor who's not
generating multiple seven figures online
and who's and not hating i'm just saying
like you're gonna go through like study
some books on marketing
whereas in this case you have this
living kind of breathing organize
organism and in the future we're going
to be making video ranking academy like
netflix meaning it will it'll be
uh continuity like you can't
pay once for netflix and get it for life
but right now the special on video
ranking academy is lifetime access
so i believe it's the absolute best
investment anybody can make
in their youtube channel if they want to
if they're really serious about it but
we also want to give people
time to plan for that or save for that
or start with a starter kit
hang out on our podcast and everything
else um to uh
get some momentum and um video ranking
academy is there however
right now is always the best time to
jump in because i remember when we first
started it years ago
it was about 60 cheaper but it gets
stronger we just rebuilt the whole
members area
and man we're so passionate about um how
world-class it is and we're also
building out a wall
of result like we actually already have
the website i know what the link is
but uh melissa's been building that out
i don't know of any program who's
actually
helped more people get crazy results and
results are not just silver play buttons
or gold play buttons i think about tanya
eliza one of our students
i was just connecting with her she's
doing you know multiple millions a year
like so some people think oh how do i
just get more reviews that's not always
the thing like there's people with
all types of different niches industries
sizes of channel
30 000 subscribers the guy is doing 300k
a year like
so it kind of that's also the thing it's
it's a program that'll help you become
business-minded about your youtube
channel and that's different than
you know someone is just like let's just
get views like it's really about the
holistic
picture of how do i build a real
business and a real
uh you know powerful high impact and
high influence
and high income youtube channel so those
are kind of the difference i hope that
makes sense
okay can i ask you before you let go i
don't want to take up your time but um
i was on an ax shoe so with the payment
for 9.97
i think i saw some today was like 97 a
month
that you can you is that option
available or 100
and then that one is uh that's just like
spreading the payment out over a year's
time
okay and uh and so and then and then
again there's like no hidden fees or
anything else
again it's just a payment plan and once
it's paid off
based on the current offer lifetime
access
and i think that's what blows a lot of
our community's mind
because once it's paid off people are
like dude i'm in like year two we first
created it
back in 2015. and you know
we're also obsessed with keeping it
current one of the biggest weaknesses
with online courses
that i've seen is people make it like
once based on information that's old
and they don't keep it updated um and
one of the ways we're able to do that
too is again
because it's a team effort and now you
see what think media is doing
nolan omar tony heather we i mean the
strength in numbers like teamwork makes
the dream work so we have
so many different perspectives and
contributors to uh making sure that it's
the
best youtube course in the world
okay appreciate you sean uh i really do
man i'm always seeing you on youtube
i always talk about the camera gear
video so i appreciate everything
appreciate you gary thanks so much for
coming on coffee with kennel all right
cheers
my man hey we're doing coffee with
kennel if you got a question about
business
uh life growing on youtube then uh
drop it or jump on uh we've got heather
helping
and there's a link to join the room is
full but we will be uh moving people in
and out of the room
so that uh we might be able to get a
couple more in here
we have lynnea did i say your name right
how's it going
hi little it's lalena uh but close la
elena yeah and uh my channel is at the
emblem plume and i'm gonna
already in a small niche of um
i do historical costuming and i've even
niched down further from my channel
um which one of the issues i'm running
into is i am getting
it seems like you know i'm getting when
i first release a video i'm getting good
ctr i'm getting good click through
and then youtube starts sharing it out
and i'm watching as my number start
going
downward and and then part of it is
because now you can look and see
like it's playing after this video i'm
like well the person watching that video
is going to have no interest in my video
um so that you know i'm like but i also
know is it my thumbnails there's so many
things that could go into it
relatively new i've got i think 19
videos up right now
so but i've been working on my
thumbnails working on my
uh titles so and then i've been
told that my you know like people when
they watch my video the ones that are
interested
they seem to have a they stay in for at
least most of it you know and i've i've
uh experimented with different times and
stuff like that and just getting all the
meat in there and none of the
you know none of the fluff
so brilliant well first of all uh thank
you so much for coming on and i want to
commend you for
how sharp you are in studying
your data like you know what gets
measured gets improved
so the fact that you're looking at your
click-through rate to start and you're
seeing it go down
but here's the facts you got to know so
first of all if you release a video
during that time the click-through rate
is going to be highest
because it is um going to be
clicked on by people who know you right
and they they serve it to your audience
first
it absolutely should go and always will
go down
as youtube releases it to more people
and it's just
can't how high can it hold on so the
confusing thing
for example i showed a video on think
media that
is crushing with only a five percent
only a five percent click-through rate
where somebody might be like well i
click the rates are 18
well you also might only have 100
subscribers and like all of them click
on it because
and so usually when your channel's
smaller and just starting we saw that
with
our think marketing channel where we
streamed coffee with kennel
is we were getting like 12 14 27
click-through rates but when you check
out think media content
it is uh being served to super wide
audiences so this is kind of a cool case
study
because this video that omar did and it
was kind of a team effort to work on
this thumbnail
you know they talk about the eyes but
you see the big eyes there of like sort
of the e.t
sort of vibe looking up at at the phone
of course the trending topic and this is
the second tip i would give you
like at some point it's not just
the click-through rate going down as
youtube's sharing it ask yourself
how wide of a market or how wide of an
audience does this video
apply to right and what i mean
specifically too
is we strategically put out this video
of how to use your smartphone as
a webcam that actually applies to almost
the whole world
going through a pandemic because almost
everybody already has a smartphone
they may that question make cross their
mind or that video gets recommended like
i didn't even know you could do that
and so on the flip side if we're like
best lenses for the canon m50
oh that video didn't get dude it's
that's super niche
like it's you know what i mean like you
have to already have that camera you
have to even care
like you may not even want a camera you
may be smartphone only so this kind of
goes into the idea of topic itself
and so in any way saying that when we
look at the click-through rate here
you can see that it what youtube does
first of all you want to see this
impressions and this is
youtube serving it to more people and as
more impressions are given out
this is what's crazy is we actually see
okay youtube's going to show this to 40
000 people a day
now it's going up it showed this to 53
000 people
on december 29th 2020 and out of those
53
000 people five percent clicked through
so the topic stayed strong the title
stayed strong the thumbnail stayed
strong
because this is a wide enough video idea
to keep getting clicked on so let's
bring it back to your channel
i would say that yes um i do think
you could make improvements if you will
we all could but you can make
improvements to your
uh thumbnails in some cases you maybe
ask yourself
um you could experiment with you in the
thumbnail and not in the thumbnail
because sometimes people want the
promise
this is the genius of like the tasty
cooking channels
like it's not about a person it's about
the result of the recipe and just seeing
the hands
and and like your your hand sewing
stitches for example like if i'm going
to learn that
but that's something to experiment with
of course maybe
i like your thumbnails but i think
sometimes
less busy so these ones with you cut out
are definitely left
less busy so uh than the ones that maybe
have this
you know more things in the background
um and
simple fonts but you're definitely
hitting that and then of course
experimenting with your content and a
lot of stuff just talked about in this
training um and as i land the plane
what i would say you know overall is
you're also just 19 in
like right you got to just clap it up
because
lalena is parking it because you started
like that's so early in the journey like
it took me like hundreds of videos of
just wandering in the desert before i
ever
started to get clarity on where i should
even go to find the promised land
so um you're doing great you're leveling
up as you go
small tweaks lead to giant peaks when it
comes to those tests
but i think the real needle mover for
you is not saying every video should try
to be the widest audience possible
but that there's some growth topics like
how can
what is true to your niche and your
personality
serve a wider market
and be a gateway into your content
is that helpful at all right yeah
actually yeah i mean that's kind of
what i was thinking i just have to
figure out what that is
and then 100 and i love that and i think
what i would encourage or just a couple
additional tips or
the mo mo the mode of operation to do
that
is is you kind of kind of want to keep
your your
it's uh i'd call it alchemy would be the
strategy
alchemy because alchemy right is when
you do alchemy and metals you combine
multiple different things you do alchemy
alchemy is um
news meets what's trending in kind of
uh your niche you know with historical
so
like what what maybe his hits a headline
what movie re brings historical you know
like forefront while at the same time
knowledge like you're already ready but
you tie it
so that that this really comes into like
positioning
kind of like psychology general
marketing
and so um and and on the one hand you
might sit down and be like i want to
force this but i almost feel like that's
why i call it like an mo like a mode of
operation
it almost becomes a lifestyle of the
content creator of like
just like maybe blogs you're following
the people you follow
that maybe are kind of in adjacent
niches
and you end up having a collection and
the way i would do this
is it's the people i learned from about
seo the people i learned from about
e-commerce
the blogs i follow e-marketer business
insider just like
i pulled into this video and then
obviously doing this for years and years
and years
and then and then eventually if you will
inspiration hits you it's like
it's like okay cool that's an angle and
then you know looking at just trends of
what's happening
and i'll be honest at think media we
just had a discussion with the team
i was like we kind of missed the content
we should have been creating about zoom
because we made our zoom smartphone
video like four
five six months after we actually should
have had it come out so
timing matters as well like as soon as
the whole world lockdown
got locked down we should have been like
full speed of like
basic webcam live streaming zoom
because that was what was happening at
that now moment
everybody watching you want to be
thinking about not just
the right topic but you really also want
to be talking about it and posting it at
the right time
that actually that's why you're one
video away from changing your whole
youtube channel
because that one video can really blow
up exposure of your channel
yourself awareness of you to a whole
nother level and never be confused that
a viral video is going to quote unquote
change your life
because you might get a million viewed
video and it may only
translate to 10 000 subscribers but
that's crazy you're at 121. you know
what i mean
and that literally everything we just
talked about easier said than done but
the alchemy
of that one video at the right time boom
it blows up
and it might be 557 000 views but then
it kind of builds a whole core audience
of super
fans like my pat says and and that kind
of puts you off to the races
and the tension you walk is
dreaming about that thinking about that
planning about that trying that and it
may or may not work you know it does
well but like it doesn't
and then just doing the day to day it's
both and it's always going through if
you will the big hits
the grand slams and the home runs and
also the base hits and just doing the
just like you're doing and being super
consistent and uh
i believe you're gonna crush it because
you're off to an incredible start
well i have video ranking academy to
thank for i mean i've been going through
it and it
is it's helped me with i'm going through
it slowly
and i'm applying it as i go which some
people do it that way some people just
re do the whole thing but
it's really given me a lot to really
the only reason why i am where i'm at
now is because of the lessons i've
learned in vra so
well awesome hey i appreciate that and
thank you so much for the feedback i
appreciate you
happy new year i hope your holidays were
uh
great and i look forward to crushing all
2021 in uh vra i'll see you in there
all right see ya all right take care
um hey what was your take away from that
one coffee with kennel family
um did you get any aha moments there um
are you talking about the right topics
are you um are you
uh what do you what was the takeaway was
there anything valuable for you let me
know
uh hit me with any comments you have in
the live chat we're gonna bring another
guest on here in just a second
um but also smash like if you've been
getting um
some value uh is daily uploads a good
thing
um yes and no
thanks so much have a good you're like
okay well that just covered everything i
mean that's
like well um here's what we would
suggest
you should upload at least one video a
week secondly
2021 it's quality over quantity
i believe that because i see too many
people doing
daily crap that was that too bold i mean
that was
like they just it's just rushed like you
get onto this treadmill of like daily is
gonna be
the thing and it's seven terrible videos
as opposed to one really strong video so
that's
i think the strategy i think it's much
more powerful in a noisy
world with so many options of what to
watch and i'm not trying to say you
gotta like over stress about the
production value i'm saying
the the effort it took to do five days
six days seven days
put more editing into one really great
video put more research and study into
one good video put more
filming and more b-roll into one good
video so
if you can increase your if you can keep
quality high then it's okay i think to
increase quantity
you might say well sean if you pay
attention
think media uploads five or six videos a
week yeah
and i think they're high quality and how
do we do that
multiple people do it like i don't know
if you've noticed that but like
this isn't even one person with the help
of an editor
it's multiple people like the way i
believe we pull off
quality and quantity
is because we're in a different season
my friend john acuff says never compare
your beginnings to somebody else's
middle someone just said in the comments
when i suggested
on some live stream somewhere that you
should focus on one a week and quality
over quantity
and they go yeah but garyvee says
that you should actually upload more
quantity and be and i said you should
focus on one social media platform
before you focus on a whole bunch of
different social media platforms and
they were like yeah
but garyvee says you should be on all of
the social media platforms
and upload like over a hundred pieces of
content a day
so i replied in the comments and i was
like yeah
well garyvee also said right i was like
yeah he does say that and garyvee also
has 20 people working for him full-time
on his personal brand publishing all
that content
and garyvee also started on one platform
called twitter in 2008 and he spent
eight hours a day on one platform called
twitter in 2008
dming and responding and biz deving with
people and answering their questions
about wine to grow his show
in 2008 called wine library tv and so
don't compare your beginning to somebody
else's middle even their strategies
come on you want to focus like you want
to do the things that people did when
they started not what they're doing
today
if you try and upload i don't even think
it's possible i would never try
to upload daily if i was doing this by
myself i would
i would get one maybe two videos out a
week depending on the systems and the
things that i had in place
before i scaled beyond that i we're on
every social media platform now
pretty much i just got in trouble
heather was like why aren't you on
clubhouse and
i was busy so i didn't actually give her
a longer response because i was like
because i'm freaking focused on youtube
like you know like angry and like slit
sleep deprived
and i know i need to be there but then
again do i because
i will be maybe uh but like we've got so
much deploying i'm worried about the
youtube strategy workshop i'm worried
about
not being a jack of all trades but being
a master of one
and then once you master one it buys you
the time to expand out
and so then you could start uploading
daily
let me ask you the question though do
you think you should upload daily
do you think it's more powerful to
upload
uh quality content rather than quantity
of content in 2021
there's exceptions to every rule i'm not
saying that you shouldn't do vlog mess
and upload 30 days in a row that could
be one of the smartest things you could
do ever
because sometimes uploading volume of
content
helps you grow helps you get faster
i'm not saying that seasons or sprints
content sprints or even the learning and
the development and the skills that you
build
from doing daily for a while i daily
vlogged with my wife for about 60 days
and quit after that but
learned so much and grew so much and
experimented so much and got to test
more titles and test more thumbnails
so there's reasons to do things but if
it comes down to the most rock solid
strategy period
janelle elena i think if you could look
at janelle elena she only has like eight
videos total
three million subs 20 million views and
if you just had a portion of that
success
she spends time making the video quality
thinking about the story thinking about
the structure editing the video
if you really study the people that are
really getting views on youtube
they just they put out high quality
videos and if they put out more videos
they keep the quality high
but i love your take on that question as
the like button is smashed on coffee
with kennel
year end edition we got matt on the show
my man
matt how's it going tell me where you're
from what your channel is all about
and uh how can i help
hey uh i'm from fargo north dakota
and i am just recently started a
non-profit
uh called without end and i've been
watching
a lot of your videos uh probably to
uh my wife's annoyance i i watch you
guys
a lot i've been trying to learn a lot um
by starting nonprofit
and i want to be able to utilize youtube
uh to organically build a community and
in turn
have that get to a point where
monetization can help provide
uh the organization's um
cost that way i can keep donations at
100 percent
uh going to the people that we want to
help serve tell me about it
and what's the nonprofit do so the dream
is that every person on the planet would
have access to
clean water safe shelter and proper
nutrition uh the way we want to do that
um and the dream that i had in doing
that was by having
one million people automate one dollar a
month
and then using that money to help meet
that need and the idea is that we can
all be involved
and not have to dig too deep in our
wallets to make a difference
man i love that so awesome vision love
what you're doing
uh show some love in the comments for
everything matt's doing
um okay so there's really two questions
when it comes to youtube and
this is relevant for a non-profit b2b
business to business or b2c business to
kind of consumer um and the question is
like who is the content for and and if
you're watching this video
you you should be thinking who is the
content
for um is the content potentially and so
let me just use a church as an example
uh is the content on a church's channel
for other pastors a church is not a
business
but that's b2b it's like for other
church leaders
or is the church is the content on the
church's channel
for the parishioners the people that
attend the church that's like b to c
the people that maybe don't care about
the leadership or about
the problems that a pastor has they want
that
end result of encouragement
the teaching et cetera so your question
becomes
who is the content for and
i thought together we could just
actually look up um
you know charity water and it looks like
they're probably not super
active on uh youtube you know they just
kind of uploading consistently
what i see here is what a lot of
nonprofits do
is they just they kind of use
um their their youtube channel as just a
repository of content
like this is a campaign video like just
something about our local partners in
action like that's not a well-written
title
uh charity water our story like that's
awesome they probably emailed that out
to their list it's probably their most
updated video
but what ends up happening is you have
to ask yourself like what value does
this add to the
end user and
who's it for is it just as a way to
educate
donors which is fine but they may or may
not want to
continue to watch these are maybe hard
questions to answer when it comes to
non-profits but one question to
ask is what kind of content could i
create
that are ideal person that would partner
with us
would want to watch every week
could i create a show that actually
adds value to the end user this is the
ultimate strategy i believe
that in and of itself is valuable
and it is used as top level
awareness for what we're doing as a
charity
that would be what i would do and that
is
a deep conversation if we were to
potentially architect what that is
but it i mean it and it could be as
simple it's been done a lot but it could
be as simple as like
um it could be
about it could be like almost an edge a
world news
show kind of a world news video podcast
and podcast
where somebody listens for the news that
it's brought to you by without end and
if you want to join us in our cause but
yet there's a reason for that person to
watch
aka listen every single week
it also could be something like five
minutes
from the front lines or something so
that would be the thing to experiment
with
because most nonprofits fall into if you
will the trap
of just kind of having a youtube channel
that's like about us
some good videos no doubt about it and
charity water's like one of the biggest
like right and so
you know one of their stories got 14
million views
in about uh in about
they may have uh uh let's see in less
than a year
but i wouldn't be surprised if they paid
they put money on this because i think
at some point they may do some you know
who knows
and that because that's a that's
actually a lot of views and
not a ton of comments so that looks like
paid ads which is also
a whole thing to think about eventually
that reinvestment into
awareness and so do you have any what's
what's your next question is we
in in response to those ideas you know
so i was
you know one of the videos you talked
about you talked about like what
uh looking for what people are asking
and um you know i'm looking at you know
like
when people trying to figure out my
target audience uh
which ideally is is everybody right you
know just getting
the idea of building a community of
people that want to just donate
one dollar a month to do that um
to to help meet those needs uh but then
trying to figure out how do i build that
community online and i'm looking like
all right let's let's see what people
like you you talked about searching like
how to's and so i was like okay how to
change the world
how to be generous how to uh give how to
you know xyz and uh
there's just not a lot there and i know
that one of the videos you said you have
two things either you're onto something
where there's nothing there
and so and that would be the wrong that
would be the wrong strategy in this case
the right strategy and here's what like
let's uh let's go an entirely out of the
box
example because you hit it on the nail
you discovered you did your research so
props because that's the key before
building the tower you want to count the
cost of building and really think
like is there even the right target
audience here but let me ask you this
if think media wanted to either
partner with and or support
uh a non-profit which we do called
compassion international but
we actually now that i think about it
like haven't really tied that into our
content
if we took our traffic
and periodically in our videos said hey
and by the way
uh at you know during the holidays this
season just so you know something that's
near and dear to our heart is a
charity a non-profit called without end
um and actually the vision is this and
if you give one dollar you can just
click the link it's just one dollar
partnering a month
the the world's gonna get clean water
and nutrition and if if that's something
you'd be willing to join omar and
heather and i doing
can you click the link in the
description below and you could you
could be a part of that
question do you think we could get some
people to sign up
yes yes because we have influence
yeah there are awareness it would touch
some people's hearts not everybody's
some people and and so
watch the math equation influence
period on how to
make a video with imovie on how to
film with your iphone on the best camera
for youtube
so when you think about building a media
company
like what actually could be the thing
that's the youtube channel
you should go after something that is a
proven aka profitable niche
because you want profit money for the
mission does that make sense
so you actually don't get necessarily so
myopic on
how to change the world but you you also
i mean it could be called like the pizza
review show like the barstool sports guy
you know what i mean like you might
start something
that is fun it may be more direct
because like maybe you have an interview
show as i discussed earlier
with like world leaders uh you know
non-profit leaders
or just whatever maybe and that's maybe
more like
super in that world or you just have a
pure if you will entertainment show or
education show
on personal finance and personal finance
a lot of competition
also a lot of channels you know it's
proven it can generate money
and one of the things you teach during
the whole time is you know one of the
most important parts of personal finance
that i actually believe is giving and
generosity it keeps your heart in the
right place
and with the money you're saving and the
tips you're learning on this channel
like would you join me in partnering
with our
nonprofit call without end just a dollar
a month you know if you've watched this
channel
like i've saved you more than that and
you even have more passive income than
that
would you consider joining me makes it
so you wouldn't even think being
personal finance
but yet that could build the influence
and then you can send that influence
potentially
wherever you want that was a pretty
decent example
as far as like a way that you know eve
it kind of ties in
but that's the way i'd be thinking and
then by the way on your target audience
uh mistakes you can make of course we
say it all the time like if you try and
reach everybody you end up reaching
nobody
yeah but if you want to narrow your
target audience we can do it pretty
quick first of all
they have to have the ability to even
give a dollar a month
so these are like good details to know
everybody watching about your target
audience that means they have a credit
card
secondly chances are they probably give
to other charities
like if you want to sell a book
authors aspiring authors it is almost
impossible to sell a book and it's
probably impossible
to somebody who's never bought a book
like it's you know what i mean like it
just
you like because they don't buy books so
but the person who does buy books
is like me and he's got like 400 books
under his desk right now
so chances are you're gonna be able to
sell me another book
like because people do every day because
i'm into books
so like they can they have a credit card
and can give one dollar
they can uh you know they probably give
to other charities
they or surely they do they're like
already
people who actually give their money um
and
and like same thing this is like
something touches our heart like we give
away a lot of money
somebody is like hey do this thing i'm
like okay like let's
and so because there's and then that's
another one then it's like
demographics is it
millennials of course it could be wider
than that but is it is it
females or males is it like you want to
start small to get big
and so seth godin is a guy i'd recommend
studying a little bit but he always says
actually try to find the smallest viable
market
ever before you do a million people
giving one dollar a month
you gotta do a hundred giving one dollar
a month then you gotta do a thousand
giving one dollar a month
and what's what's that smallest you know
again like
churches people of faith like generous
people who are
already so you maybe think and then you
might think a particular local church or
particular denomination
or it could be some you know something
else in regards to like philanthropy or
people that are
so uh we we go into that in some of our
other trainings and stuff but that's
that's target audience that's like where
you really drill down into some of those
details
which then potentially helps you
architect um
the type of content that will
attract that target audience that will
build influence period and once
influence is built
then it can lead to income and impact
and that's why you know our video
influencers tagline we always say like
help you build your
influence income and impact because it
is linear like that
it is actually people need to know you
first even if it was on think media and
they hey they know sean they know
heather they know omar
and it's like hey uh do you want to be a
part of this nonprofit
no but someone else goes yes and then
that leads into the money for the impact
and the change
yeah no that was great and uh i don't
take anybody else's time
i wanted people get in i really
appreciate what you guys are doing
appreciate the time to uh talk with me
love what you're doing matt love your
heart for the world and uh grateful
you're part of our community and thanks
for coming on coffee with kennel
absolutely y'all have a good one
i am sean cannell this is coffee with
cannell if you're just
joining this show is on the think
marketing youtube
channel which is our new channel did you
know we have a video podcast and a
podcast
did you know we have a new channel
you're like i'm watching it right now
well i appreciate you being here
and uh all 20 21 long we are um
uh drop in every tuesday we call it the
tuesday ritual
where drop in episodes this week's
episode was 10
business and youtube lessons i learned
from 2020
the host of the think marketing podcast
is
the incontrovertible heather taurus
and um she uh hosts that podcast
we have guest on we talk we talk with
the think media team
i do solo rounds she does solo rounds
the vision of the podcast
is to help you not just build a
successful
youtube channel but to build a business
around that youtube channel it's really
like the youtube startup
for startup companies youtube is the
greatest traffic generator
so many different ways to monetize and
it goes deeper because if you're really
going to thrive
on youtube you i believe need to master
modern marketing
content creation and business and online
business
so if you want a place where you can go
deeper into those topics those concepts
head to spotify head to apple head to
google
and subscribe to the think marketing
podcast have you listened to it yet have
you heard an episode did you know we
have a podcast
are you already subscribed let me know
in the comments hit like if you're
having fun on coffee with kennel today
let me know a question or topic you
would like us to cover
on the think marketing podcast and that
my friends is our new channel it's a
year old
24 000 subscribers in a year like what a
year
kind of a year of experimenting getting
going and then
our main channel is called think media
and maybe you've heard about think media
before this now
is a team brand a media company
with omar and nolan and heather and tony
and myself
creating content to help you really with
the best tools
like cameras live streaming gear
software as well as youtube strategies
if you want a little a little snookit
like what the heck what's what's the
snookit
i meant nugget chicken nugget
dang i'm so hungry i gotta go to the
bank in a second so i do gotta bounce
soon
like like you know like just like a flex
like instead of me that
like ah i gotta go to the bank uh but
but uh uh this whole shorter strategy
is kind of how we think about think
media i mean we put some long johns on
here for sure
but i don't think we haven't put a video
out that's over an hour long in like
forever
so when we talk about and if you're just
joining watch the beginning with the
three tips but notice a lot of sevens a
lot of eights a lot of nines
and uh this next year we're gonna be
even hit and we're hitting the twos
two minutes and 12 seconds um and so
think about that shorter versus longer
videos and hey
youtube shorts we got some new content
coming out on that soon
as well have you tried youtube shorts
yet
are you wearing shorts right now or is
it
colder where you are uh
that's right we got heather taurus in
the chat today
a snippet plus a nugget is a snugget
snugget have you tried youtube shorts
let me know what do you think about him
uh ella says yes subscribe thank you so
much for being subscribed
uh seven souls paranormal thanks so much
for sharing all this with us you're
you're welcome appreciate you being a
part of the community thanks for being
here
and uh we'll bring a couple more people
on the show here before we land
the plane will changing titles and
thumbnails renew interest in old videos
it's not a bad idea but the only way um
you're gonna be able to renew interest
in old videos is potentially if you're
still
getting some level of search and
discovery or some level
of um impressions
aka reach what do you mean sean
i'm glad you asked so um
like this is an interesting thing
because sometimes if it ain't broke
don't
fix it okay so here's one of my videos
by the way
breaking my own rule at two hours and
five minutes but it's doing pretty well
videos generated uh almost 12 grand 1.5
million views
um and you notice like just insane
results and continued results
okay so you go to reach and here's your
question you go to reach in the last
seven days
every single day youtube is showing this
video to 52 000 people 61
000 people 63 000 people that's an
impression they have a chance to click
on it
so puko's porch will changing titles and
thumbnails renew interest in old videos
okay well this one obviously still has
interest
but here's the interesting thing
changing the title or the thumbnail
of this video could actually raise this
number
right like it already is being seen so
it'll keep being shown
to at least 40 000 people for the next
couple days
and if the click-through rate goes up
and the average view duration goes
up then that new title and thumbnail
could
could actually increase these this reach
and all the overall results
however i don't want to change the title
and thumbnail
because it's already doing well and i
might do better or it might do worse and
like i don't want to mess with the good
thing maybe i should who knows okay
also by the way see how low this
click-through rate is but
i wouldn't worry about that because a
the average view duration is high and
this video has been shown
to so many dang people like this video
has had 26 million impressions
so when your video gets that many
impressions
um it's going to be a lower
click-through rate the higher the
impressions it'll drive down your
click-through rate
notice this too for the first like
couple months of this video it did all
right and then once youtube saw ah
there's some watch time on this guy
what a ride that guy was that was that
was a party right through that
era and then it's still doing strong and
okay so
so to answer your question then um
it is definitely if you're gonna change
a title or a thumbnail you could change
it
but you're gonna maybe wanna like prime
the pump because you might not be
getting any impressions you should go
look
um but even if you're getting a hundred
or 10
like a new title new thumbnail could
increase click-through rate average view
duration that's probably not going to
increase average iteration although it
might
because the content didn't change and
it it could really help uh or it might
not do anything or it might hurt but
what i would suggest
is share it on social re-push it because
you need to get people
watching it again to get youtube kind of
going on it again
to see if that click-through rate
improves so
on the one hand puko's porch i would say
don't worry about it too much but it may
be something you want to do to say the
top
your top videos i wouldn't worry about
your losers
quote unquote out of your last 100
videos i actually might re-optimize
your most popular videos and or your
most relevant videos maybe you have a
good like search-based how-to video
with like just kind of a boring
thumbnail and let's say you were doing
cooking
and it really was just much more vibrant
much more clickable
with maybe much more of an inviting
title i think that also
most people who go through the youtube
starter kit like
go oh my gosh and they have to like have
to but they go back and change
a lot of old things because they were
doing things quote unquote so wrong
like titles were just flat not clickable
and and definitely if like you know
maybe the way to put it is not trying
not
not trying to make like a good or great
title even greater
but if it's a bad title you definitely
should make it at least
good and so some of those tweaks could
happen but i think your next video will
be your best video
the future is forward always be thinking
about probably your your next video the
most
um and especially uh let me give you one
strategy that'll break this kind of down
you put out new videos you keep growing
you get more subscribers
eventually you have a community tab once
you have a community tab
you should be using your community tab
to re-promote older
videos once you have a community tab
if you're using it to re-promote your
older videos because your new
subscribers don't necessarily know about
your back library
you may want the new title on that
community tab
or the new description on that community
tab
to be more clickable so i believe this
is a great
bright little thumbnail and this goes
into the idea that actually your
community tab should be a square
and not a rectangle that's a
conversation for another day but we got
the link there
so we're using uh our community tab to
promote
our greatest hits all the time sometimes
just with photography sometimes with
images
but does that make sense you may want to
do like
kind of like the when they do a 10th
anniversary version of a book
and it's more or less the same book but
they put a little bit of polish on it
new cover
they change the title up maybe a little
or they do like 2.0 or something
and then they re-promote it definitely
think about running some of your old
videos through that
um and uh my friend matt gielen had a
good video about some tests they did
and they actually saw some tests where
some videos went from a
four percent click-through rate to a
five and a half percent click-through
rate although i think you could maybe
get too bogged down in that
and not be worrying enough about your
next video which i believe will be your
best video
today's coffee with kennel is brought to
you by the youtube strategy workshop and
the youtube starter kit
let me know if you're signed up are you
going to be here this saturday
9 a.m pacific time to 1 p.m
pacific time um heather torres tony
areola we're going to be
live streaming we're going to do a whole
training plus if you do want to level up
your titles
your video ideas your thumbnails money
making strategies
some cool surprise bonuses that you
don't even know that are in there
uh you're going to absolutely love this
starter kit it's 600
of resources it's like 800 or something
actually because we added the
training normally it is a 97
uh on sale for 97. that's the normal
sale
and that goes up in like a week
right now you can get it for 37 one of
the
absolute no-brainer decisions you can
make to invest in your youtube channel
you'll absolutely love it
and you get a ticket to our youtube
strategy workshop
okay so you're gonna learn how to start
your channel or grow your channel with a
busy life
in five hours or less less like the five
hour youtube work week plan heather's
training on that
you jump start your channel by planning
a whole year's worth of content in one
hour
tony's breaking down some stuff i'll be
going deeper video topics
uh you're gonna learn the exact videos
you should be making in 2021
um and so pretty pretty no miss
and you can get a free ticket it's a
bonus with the youtube starter kit link
in the description below
tubestarterkit.com
you're gonna love it check it out
details down there click that up
okay let's bring a couple more people on
before the plane gets
landed today we got amy
give it a go baking welcome to the show
uh tell me thank you about yourself
um i just started my youtube channel
like in october
um my brother kind of is helping me he's
like hey you should put these little
video clips of like uh something i do
later in the video at the beginning
so i've been trying to use those as like
my hook
at the beginning so um my
question for that is should i do like
clips that are coming and telling
people what i'm going to be talking
about and use like the b-roll with
like over here while i'm talking
great question so what we're gonna do is
gonna watch one of your videos together
okay this is it right
yeah which one should i watch any of
them um
one of the last two are probably the
better ones
all right we're gonna watch this one
here we go probably my favorite dessert
i think i've ever tried
[Music]
my husband got a wood fire pizza oven
for his birthday
so today we're gonna try it out and
we're gonna make a dessert pizza
elvis style okay so that's pretty good
first 15 seconds a little bit of
personality
a little bit of music came in and you've
promised me
what's gonna happen um you are it looks
like you are showing me the final result
here
um but what i would suggest is um
working on the clarity
of of this and um
you know uh
tony ariola and his wife started a new
channel called the plant-based kitchen
and so he started studying um
uh food photography and so
he these are like thumbnails and whatnot
and
because you want that that first promise
to be like
super inviting and food photography
would also include
b-roll aka the video clips um
of what's coming up okay i think that
this then also is a great opener to
consider
because what he's teasing so it's kind
of exactly what you said and my answer
is yes
and the first hey guys 15 seconds here
it was like here's what's coming up
we're going to chop it up
we're going to show you each step we're
going to show you the thing you know
what i mean and then it's and
show you the final result and so you're
definitely on to that
but i think those are the tweaks to make
is how quickly you quote unquote
lovingly punch the viewer in the face
uh with with what's coming up get to the
point quick
um and so my friend uh benji
on his cooking channel too like let's
check out uh
this intro here let's watch this crispy
crispy salty perfectly delicious
that's right french fries everybody's
favorite side dish or
snack and use so i love how he did that
because he's like
oh now i'm getting hungry crispy salty
and he's showing you and then he shows
up on camera
and let's check it out you get this when
you go to a burger joint or restaurant
but guess what we're at home we're
cooking a lot more
i'm going to show you the easiest way to
do it you don't even have to deep
eazy's a really strong powerful i mean
you know because that's what people want
the average person is not like i'm going
to show you how a pro
chef with massive skill that is
inaccessible by the average person like
nobody wants to watch that easy
we're going to be using the stove and
baking it you can make a big batch of
this
i think for cookie tutorials it's
important to think about um
the method because there's so many
different things like so
tantalize you know i want to see it i
saw the b-roll and here's the thing
this is easy if you're a beginner you
could do this
all you need is this thing this thing
and this thing and what and all i'm
breaking down is what you ask
is the hook like what could we pack into
the hook to
grab the viewer and sell the viewer on
watching the rest of the viewer
video cook other things at the same time
that it's baking so let's go ahead and
get right into the ingredients
first thing is the potatoes as you can
and then of course
you also might be like what the heck man
these guys video production
benji's been doing this for years you
know uh
cami is married to a video production
expert
uh you know tony but those are some some
principles
i think i would think and those types of
small tweaks
lead to giant peaks i think could really
help what's a follow-up question
um let me go back on my notes um
so is the lower third
also considered a part of the b-roll
yeah i think more thirds or these titles
um
yeah yeah that's definitely i would
consider b-roll
or just a way to hold attention
it reminds me of like i don't know what
the dating show was
maybe somebody could like or maybe
there's a lot of them where like bubbles
would pop
up like fun fact about tom is that he
was a baseball player when he grew up
and you're like oh
i love love connection or something like
that
so so i mean other things that hold
attention you're absolutely on to it
furthermore um if you can put a list
if you could put supportive numbers on
screen or amounts on screen
and potentially do a split screen
you're training and showing but they can
actually see that ingredient list
and maybe leave it up those all can
enhance it for sure
okay i'll learn how to do that what are
you editing with
my phone it's a little app called you
cut
you're doing great this is amazing i'm
trying to learn how to do
editing and then like promoting it
and oh that wasn't one more question i
had
um so i follow the johnsons
for their instagram tips so
should i spend most of my time
commenting on other
cooking videos within youtube
or should i try to keep going like on
instagram i started a whole nother page
and try to connect with people there
like i don't know
what is the best thing to do to grow
what are your subscribers
like what do you want to happen if by
the end of 2021
you either had instagram influence and
some kind of strategy you want that's
similar to what chalene would teach over
there
or 10 000 subscribers on youtube
and youtube i'm kind of you know it
answers the question already
okay so of course it's about reverse
engineering and like
self-awareness of knowing what it is you
want to grow in my opinion
it's difficult if not impossible to grow
your youtube channel with
an instagram account um even almost it's
it's almost it's very difficult to move
audiences period you grow them one place
you can but it's always such a small
percentage therefore
the best way to grow a youtube channel
is
on youtube and the best way to grow an
instagram account is on instagram
and i'm all for instagram and we
actually have chalene's doing some
training with us
in february and and were absolutely love
her stuff but it's
knowing where's your focus today so if
i'm you
my strategy is um
number one really dialing in your
youtube
content and you're doing great but i
think
like i don't i don't love this title as
a good example part one
part one i don't even know you yet like
what is part one
at the end of the title if not the
beginning making a dessert
pizza like i would rather see this title
formulated as like
dessert pizza colon something something
something something
parentheses part one so that's just like
the restructuring of the title
definitely for example i would be of
course doing your keyword research
and maybe like type stuff in like that
and then i try to put those as
the tags but but the key is you research
before you press record
so it's not even necessarily yes you
could put these as tags
but this research should influence the
actual content so my point is this
by starting here you should actually
keep going deeper
and actually do a uh
you know cinnamon sugar
dessert pizza or a a dessert pizza with
pre-made crust
and the reason that is the video that
you did is because you did the keyword
research first
then furthermore the title becomes uh
how
you know dessert pizza how to make
pre-made cuss
crust that is and being really
strategic in research before you press
record coming up with the video idea
architecting the content around that
because here's the result i'd be looking
for you're just
as we talked we talked about in our
program video ranking academy you're one
ranked video away from changing your
life from business
you put out dessert pizza with pre-made
crust
that video gets 100 views 800 views 2
000 views 2 500 views over the next
couple months
that's not unrealistic you find the
right video about the right recipe and
the right topic
in fact um i'm not even a you know
uh like cook but
i am a youtube video ranking
expert right and so i
over the years when i was perfecting my
process i would do stuff like um
oven baked salmon
in info in foil okay okay
and eight years ago
that's just pounds fresh atlantic salmon
fillets
bait oven tin foil pouch recipe made
easy
here's the ingredients you're gonna need
salt pepper
extra virgin olive oil or light extra
okay so
so eight years ago right
three hundred and three thousand views
been doing this for a minute
affiliate link in my top link to uh it's
a four-hour chef by tim ferriss
has nothing to do with the video but you
know you got to do what you got to do
you need money for the mission
and so uh this
uh this video is so specific
i want you answering specific questions
i learned this recipe from my dad uh
stepdad
and the key is it wasn't just baked
salmon
it was oven baked so it's not grilled on
a grill
it's not you know um it wasn't just um
and it it was in an oven and it was also
in
foil so the layers it wasn't in a pan it
wasn't in a
glass i don't even know what you call
things i have no right to be teaching
this video but apparently 303 000 views
and so i just was sharing this recipe
like the only recipe i know i know like
three recipes and they all turn into
youtube videos
and so um you know
that's kind of an answer to your
question
that is your answer to your your growth
if the research before you press record
is the make the right videos
is over eight years eight years later
having three hundred and three thousand
views or thirty five thousand views
because of the way you structure your
videos get
definitely improve your your titles your
thumbnails but you know to be
overwhelmed or discouraged by that it's
getting one percent better with every
upload
and like tony said he's like i actually
took like a skillshare course or
whatever
on like food photography and like design
like as i think about this is a marathon
and not a sprint so
of course you're maybe hustling and
really but like
be patient you know think about okay as
i'm making my 2021 plan what skills do i
want to learn this year
and i'm going to focus on one aspect of
my channel i really want to keep doing
videos and get better
but i'm really going to focus on making
the thumbnails better and learning canva
and heather has a great training how do
you do your thumbnails um i
usually like well now i started i
listened to one of the podcasts
um and so i started doing like pictures
of when i'm baking it
um and then like i put it there and then
i'll do like
my face and i'll be like or something
something like that
um to try to like i try to think about
the thumbnail
before i actually do the video
cool well final tip on that too and i
think you know so keep leveling up one
percent better with every video
you and all cooking channels and all
channels
is success leaves clues success leaves
clues
and here's what i mean um it is my
opinion
that you actually don't need words on
your titles and that you do not need to
be
uh word you don't need words on your
thumbnails
and you also do not need to be in the
thumbnails and the reason why
in your niche is that data
proves it and so if we say uh
banana what's the data sean like
the top performing videos so if i look
at
banana pecan cake um
okay sure you know little black text but
actually unnecessary in my opinion
that one little logo in the upper right
but also
and notice some fresh looking bananas a
little bit of like
depth of field there what kind of phone
do you have uh
i think it's an s10 yeah so you might
have
like is it but i mean with good lighting
get some natural lighting in there and
get some stuff
you could take great photos on there um
and so if i look at something
like pizza sauce and and most cooking
videos now
it doesn't mean you can break any rules
but success leaves clues like
really think about um what are the
top performing videos and what can i
learn about them just a really good
picture of what i'm gonna get and then a
good title
uh you know a great picture of what i'm
gonna get an old-school video that
can do okay necessarily you know that's
maybe not as good but
you know this is two pizza sauces oh
like juxtaposition
so that also when it comes to your
research phase think about also
researching
your if you will competitors or the
other videos
of course craft your own style of course
experiment
you can do anything you want but that is
one tweak i would make
and before after the recipe you don't
have to worry about like cutting
yourself out or
you know you can experiment with having
you in the thumbnail as well i just
don't think it's necessary so then in my
case
i'm trying to take your final dish go
outside
put it on like a table in daylight have
a little like plant kind of coming into
the corner
start snapping some photos and like okay
wow that's like a really great photo and
in a way
that might be like all you need maybe
and take a class
on free youtube videos or something you
know
i have a iphone 11 uh pro
max or whatever it takes pretty good
photos
but nothing compared to what i edited
them after like they're super flat the
saturation's not high enough
the blacks and they don't punch enough
you could do some sharpening yeah
and i just i know there's some ninjas in
the comments let me know what apps what
photo editing
apps you use here in the community but i
just use the iphone app
and i just i do a little you know i mess
with those features so you just watch
like
put on your calendar schedule your
personal development we call it a pdp
your personal development plan schedule
like
okay this coming week in addition
everything else i'm gonna do
for an hour i'm gonna watch videos about
how to take great photos on my phone
and videos about how to edit photos on
my phone so you can get
some vibrant photos of your pumpkin
maple macaroons okay
was this helpful yes very very
thank you so much hey i appreciate you
so much and thanks so much for coming on
coffee with kennel today
thank you hey friends
uh smash like if you're getting value
today my name is sean cannell this is
the coffee with kennel show
i'm the founder of think media um and
this is our new channel
think marketing where we do this show
every other week
what happens on the opposite week
heather taurus
um does a show called think marketing
live and you're not going to want to
miss those
we're doing better at like promoting and
scheduling them sean when do these
happen
i don't know i mean once a week meaning
it's not the same time date or place yet
but uh
we will do our best to schedule them
like a day in in advance so make sure
you subscribe and you have notifications
turned on
and then if you're able to join us for
one um she also you know of course
brings people on and the cool thing
about heather is she's probably the
smartest digital marketing strategist in
the world that i know
um she's really smart with youtube
clarity helping people get clarity and
there's like an episode
where she will do some training and then
she just like this will bring on
guests and so uh if you want
to kind of figure out man how do i
master my message
how do i master confidence um how do i
find my niche
you know how do i actually create a
business plan around this
and all those types of things plus
the deep end of email marketing paid
traffic
uh she's incredible and so every other
week she does think marketing live
and then i do the coffee with kennel
show and we're pumped because we
in our opinion your first year of
youtube by the way for us too
like clearly because of think media and
other things
think marketing is what it is um it's
grown quicker
but my friends in our first year we
considered experimental
like we were just trying to figure out
like what to do this year our first year
of the video podcast
like you know there's like beta and then
you launch things in alpha
i think it's a year of just beta like
give yourself permission to experiment
give yourself permission to figure out
your cadence figure out what works
you know coffee with cannell on the
think marketing live show didn't even
exist that was also kind of inspired by
the pandemic and we got locked down and
we're like what are we gonna do
we should hang out with people more like
we should answer questions
we're not traveling anywhere like and so
that's where these things came out of
experimenting and now we sort of were
like figuring out our game plan testing
different ideas
i don't encourage you to do the same if
you're still in your first year of
youtube and let me know
how long have you been on youtube how
long you've been posting videos
your first year's experimentation take a
deep breath
relax give yourself some grace
don't be overly judgmental of your
results at the start
and when you're really just starting
because again we started with think
media
you might be starting from zero row
everywhere
you really want to give yourself grace
and patience and time to
post videos get comfortable on camera
learn the different things you need to
learn and let your first
like when you study a mr beast or
whoever they do like 100 videos
pewdiepie
250 videos it takes time
to build something great and you don't
have to be great to start but you have
to start to be great you just got to
start posting
and they got to stick with it because
most people
overestimate what they can accomplish in
one year
but they underestimate what they can
accomplish in five to ten years
and i think if you really are taking
youtube serious
you need to make a mental and heart
commitment
not that it's gonna take like five years
but that
it might and are you willing to not take
five years
of dabbling and rarely ever posting and
thinking a lot but never taking action
no like five years of actually going for
it
you know and when you look at think
media's channel on the lifetime of this
channel
you know now it's over 100 million views
um
and you look at the first five years
like the first five years of think media
this looks pretty flat and by the way
flat
is not that flat like this is 160 views
a day
this is this is 287 views a day in 2012.
like this is this is daily views so
that's awesome like 555 views
but compared to this it's all this blue
craziness over here where things really
got interesting
it's it's pretty insignificant
in comparison but never
judge a seed by its season growing deep
roots in the soil
because this was a preparation season
for me this was me learning growing
working on my craft you know
making mistakes being spread too thin
working on too many different projects
then i saw a little bit of green uh
leaf pop through the the soil right here
oh a thousand views a day
oh man things start getting interesting
around 2015.
okay i start seeing a little growth a
little groot come on
i'm groot you know little pops up the
little guy
and now i'm starting to grow now as
things are starting to happen and
now in 2016 okay now 50 000 views a day
like it's starting to be more
interesting 30 000
you know and you go okay wow
still nobody knows who i am but now it's
like oh dang
sean's like a youtuber because i was
like full-time right in here
okay like right around here but still
and then you're like oh shoot and let me
know how long you've been a part of
think media you know what i mean or like
how long you've been watching our
content
then you step up to here now we're at
100 000 views a day
128 000 so
what's the point don't despise small
beginnings what's the point
are you willing to just put in the work
and put in the hustle and i believe that
if you get connected to smart strategies
you can shorten your learning curve i
don't believe there are short cuts those
can be dangerous
like you leave the proven path and fall
off a cliff
so there are but they're smart cuts it's
a good book by the way by shane
snow smart cuts oh that's a really good
book tell us the story of michelle phan
um and kind of you know one of the
youtube greats and a lot of other cool
stories
about going faster but it's still going
to take time so i want to encourage
you be patient on the journey be willing
to commit to excellence
to commit to putting out the best videos
possible when
nobody's watching be willing to spend
your season in obscurity
to prepare you for popularity be willing
to put in the work for six months twelve
months
three years five years and if you can
shorten your learning curve because
people are breaking out even in our
community
they break out in six months eight
months year and a half
dr eye health silver play button and
like multiple thousands a month nearing
10
000 i think of income in like two years
like there's all kinds of different
results uh but
what's really interesting is committing
i want to say five years of like
good videos good titles good thumbnails
getting better
learning marketing learning business
leveling up personal growth
personal development and you might go
dang bro that sounds tough well yeah
that's the grit
that it takes to i believe actually step
into this arena
but it's a way more practical than you
think as we land the plane today
you haven't been studying the creator
economy a whole another thing
and uh there's this article that came
out
i'll link this up in the description
down below you know there's 50 million
content creators
this is a very detailed study okay
now there's one million professional
content creators on youtube professional
equals six figures a year so this study
revealed that they're
making at least six figures a year now
hold the
phone who needs six figures a year to
live
someone in the comments like i do that's
i can't live off six figures okay cool
like i don't know where you live what
the cost of living is but just by
definition they're saying
a professional youtube creator there's a
million
of those guys and girls that are earning
six figures plus so
thousands are earning seven figures
hundreds of thousands
hundreds of thousands are using uh six
figures but then you have these 12
million amateur creators over here and
that might be
where you'd find yourself and what's
fascinating to me
is those uh that category is
you know you may be earning nothing you
may be earning 500 bucks a year
5 000 a year um and you may be earning
10 grand a year
or but the
vision i want to cast as we start
thinking about because basically this
whole article breaks down
how bright the future is for the creator
economy
how it's only going to continue to grow
how
it is the listen and i quote fastest
growing small business type
like this is a real business and this
can be really practical
now this could do you could take me out
of context and be like sean's just
saying it's easy
you never heard me say that but i am
saying it's practical
and i am saying that there's a whole
group an
opportunity available for those that are
willing to really commit
invest the grit the persistence the
perseverance
the humility to admit they don't know
everything
and to work on leveling up day by day by
day
because they see a vision they reverse
engineer a plan and a path and they just
put in the work and hustle
and the thing is a lot of people start
very few sustain so a lot of people give
it a go
i tried five videos i tried 30 videos i
tried 50 videos i tried 100 videos
i tried it for a year now i'm also not
saying that there's never a time to
actually say like it's not really
working or i don't vibe with it or like
i can't balance it with family
like avoid the extremes
right it could take not that i feel the
need to defend myself
maybe i've been accosted in the comments
too uh like
you know like of course you can take it
all out of context but the point is
if you really think okay this is a
business this is a small
business type this is a real economy
there's billions of dollars this article
reveals flowing into
creators software money finance
it is a massive it's the fastest growing
small business type
so you go okay what's my business plan
what is my plan how am i approaching
this and are you approaching this
if you and your spouse or you by
yourself or you and a friend
opened up a local coffee shop you and a
friend opened up a local fitness
uh gym opened up a local crossfit if you
and a friend
opened up a little juicing a local
juicing store if you and a friend
opened up a local insurance agency
you're not working on that freaking
business two hours a week
you're not lazily showing up unshowered
not ready for work with your office
clean and your front desk ready to grind
and so you're going to show up to that
business and come hell or high water
you're going to work on that thing
you're going to hustle on that thing
you're going to be a professional in
that thing you're going to turn
pro on that thing and you're gonna work
on it for one year two years three years
four years and five years
and they say the average business owner
only becomes like profitable
and can take his head above the water a
little bit after five years
that it actually takes five years of
grit and hustle in any business
real estate agent whatever not until you
can pay the bills necessarily
but until you even have any of the
amenities or luxuries
of a business owner meaning there's a
little bit of automation there's a
little bit of like
not just trying to make ends meet until
the month ends there's a little bit of
stability
in your business are you willing
to put in the hustle for the next five
years can you give me three
and are you willing to treat it like a
real business treat it like a real
professional
treat it like you're actually serious
treat it with the respect it deserves
with how many people actually want to be
a part of the creator economy
a lot of people want to do this because
it's freaking amazing
and i really believe that with the right
plan and the right strategy and the
right mindset
and the right hustle when you find the
right niche and you identify your
strengths and you play to your strengths
that it can be very practical do i think
everybody will become a millionaire from
youtube no
do i think the majority of people can
earn
an extra five grand a year an extra
eighteen thousand dollars a year
or make a thirty five thousand dollar a
year income in the long tail of youtube
opportunity
one hundred 100 read the article i'll
link it up in the description down below
and uh let me know what's your goal on
youtube is it your goal to go full time
is it your goal to uh you know make just
some part-time income
are you building a hobby channel let me
ask you
do you think of yourself as a business
on youtube or do you think yourself
as just like a content creator treating
this like a
hobby um let me know and
one of my favorite quotes if you are
thinking about
a mindset shift okay when it comes to
this youtube thing is from jay-z
and if you're a youtuber this is you
okay
i'm not a businessman i'm a
business comma man
right like you're a business and
when you think about the creator economy
it's it there's definitely it's thick
it's moving from dabbling to dominating
it's moving into the mindset
needed adam right
i'm not a businessman i'm a business man
so uh we got goals here we got amy my
goal is to supplement my income for my
family trying for it to be a business
um and amy again like on the other side
of execution we've talked
this is a real thing meaning
after a year i think you could be at 10
000 subscribers maybe more but i think
you could be 10 000 by the end of 2021
i think from just seeing your channel
and and by the way on the other side
of a freaking lot of work and hustle and
intentionality
not necessarily the amount of hours but
the amount of work you put into the
hours the amount of strategy you put
into the hours of course it's going to
take time
but heather this saturday's talking
about the five hour youtube work week so
it doesn't have to be
you know there's different ways to
approach it but a lot of people kirby
full-time business
mapping out mapping the mind of god
full-time
melania my goal is to build my personal
personal brand it's awesome to see all
these different goals
that i you have here um
and let's see
does the uh starter kit help with
building a media kit
no but and i'm not saying like if you
get it it does not cover that
it's still worth it and beyond 10 times
so tubestarterkit.com however uh we are
always up
just like we update video ranking
academy we're always updating things
i love that idea we um we could uh
heather let's like just you know
sometime in 2021 and by the way like
when you invest in a program like the
starter kit
they've even seen people that have
jumped into starter kit over time you
get the updates you get the upgrades to
it so
we um there's already one thing i'm
gonna be adding to it
in like the next month and so i will
absolutely
collect our best information about
building a media kit really in brand
deals
and throw a resource in that but it's
not there right now just
for clarity um for that so
uh hobbyist wanting to go full time
monogramming plus
so i love uh
your vision and everything you've been
sharing and melina says i've been
learning
or molina how to treat it as a business
awesome i really appreciate that i want
to say thanks for the super sticker
from tuber tips thank you so much for
that i can see that in stream yard now
what a crazy
world we live in that is crazy
and um i want to again
thank you for being here today what is
your goal fam share it in the comments
what's your goal with
youtube as we land the plane uh thank
you for hanging out today
friends uh we will do more coffee with
channels in the future today's
uh episode is brought to you by
thetubestarterkit.com if you're just
hearing about that link in the
description down below for all the
details
of uh our special that's ending in like
seven days or less so if you want to get
over 90
off of the youtube starter kit and a
free ticket
as a bonus to our youtube strategy
workshop that is coming up in just a few
days
there will be a replay um but it's four
hours this coming saturday depending on
when you're watching this
tubestarterkit.com hit like if you got
value out of the video today
um once a week bringing you coffee with
kennel once a week bringing you the
thick marketing live show
five videos a week on our channel think
media
i appreciate you want to wish you a
happy new year
happy holidays thank you for being a
part of our
community thank you for your attention
thank you for every like
every comment if you're a vra member
thank you if you jumped in the starter
kit
thank you um if you're here and you hear
my voice thank you
if you've you know clicked the dislike
button and dropped
some criticism thank you i just want to
say
it matters to me and is meaningful
for me that um you would share a little
bit of your attention
uh with myself and the think media team
i really do appreciate you i respect you
for being a person who's investing in
yourself leveling up
you're not watching a 1 hour and 57
minute and 38
second stream if you're not
into growth into becoming a better
person for tomorrow
which also tells me that you're a role
model and a leader
and that you're probably a pillar for
those around you
you're probably someone that others
depend on
and that others look to for strength and
that
is fighting for yourself your family
your future
and so i just want to say i respect you
for doing the work
i respect you for investing in yourself
i respect you for being a part of
our community at whatever level and even
if we never get to talk again
i hope that you feel love and kindness
and gratitude from me
um on this live stream today or if you
happen to be watching this on the replay
um i'm grateful for you 2020 was tough
let's make 20 20 21 amazing and even if
we face many more crisis is which we
might
never forget that hidden in every crisis
is opportunity
and uh it's kind of like what they say
when life gives you lemons make lemonade
it's not about your resources it's about
your resourcefulness it's about what you
do
uh with what is coming your way
and i believe together in the think
marketing
brands and community we're gonna work
together to make 2021 the best year ever
and help you get results on youtube
if you're looking to build a high impact
and high profit channel
my name is sean cannell this has been
coffee with cannell
and i will see you in the next video